hi joe
good morning k thanks for having me
hi it's nice to see you tell me about
how you're keeping up your fitness
routine and and what we're going to do
for i'm going to say toddlers but
they're not really they're most sort of
pre-school aren't they
here joe obviously ended i wanted to
continue the mission which is to inspire
and engage young children in exercise
and really have fun of it and get them
to enjoy the connection to movement and
how they feel so i partnered up with hey
dougie the most loved obviously tv
character at the moment and do a series
of workouts of children so i've got a
sort of young child either side of me
and we're thrown into this virtual world
with dougie and the squirrels and it's a
really short sort of eight to ten minute
workout which is about having fun and
just energizing the children and i think
they're gonna love them i'm posting one
a day um for the next 13 days on my
youtube channel on the body coach tv
that's amazing we're actually looking at
as a clip from the video as we're
chatting to you um joe really important
to get little ones uh moving as quickly
as possible really
i think it's so important to get young
children especially you know even
preschool is thinking about how exercise
makes them feel you know from a mental
health perspective for their energy for
how it makes them feel a bit less
stressed and a bit calm i i really
worked that out from a very young age
that as a kid i i could see that one
exercise i had more focus i was happy i
dealt with stress and what was going on
at home in my life through fitness and
movement so i think if we can get our
young children enjoying it and having
fun with it from the youngest age you're
really going to set them up for an
active you know
adulthood i think okay how long does it
take and what what's your guidance and
advice to parents
so the workouts are really fun and
interactive so i've made them really you
know there's some really basic moves so
we've got kind of at the end of each
workout they're called the workout
package so dougie and the squirrels take
part with you in this kind of virtual
world and at the end dougie brings down
the badge and children get rewarded with
their little badge so it's a really
great mechanism and i was doing it my
little daughter indian i sat down for a
couple and she said daddy you're not
going to get your bag so it's a really
good way of keeping them inspired it's a
very short workout
and yeah they're just super fun and i
think kids are gonna love them
regardless even if they're a little bit
older you know with their little
brothers and sisters they're gonna have
a great time doing them yeah what about
the rest of us um we certainly started
in the first lockdown working out quite
a lot didn't we and then people got a
little bit more
complacent and people always talk about
that locked down half stone now
yeah when we're emotional you know we
tend to eat and we obviously we're
sedentary we're in our houses a lot more
we weren't moving as much but i just try
and encourage people to be active it
could be the simplest things like
walking to the shops you know and going
through a bike ride or getting on the
scooter with kids like getting out of
the house and getting some fresh air can
really help but you know basic moves at
home i've got i can demonstrate a couple
of exercises from the workout badges um
because you know they're very low impact
they're fun they're simple moves anyone
can take fun they're quite animated so
the first one from um
the episode one's called the rainbow
battery sort of coming up and over like
following the rainbow so it's a bit of a
movement like that and they're fun and
you know i think kids are gonna love
parents also like have fun take part
because i think if you can do it
together you can really have a bit of
fun and connect through exercise and
really inspire each other sort of
motivate each other to keep coming back
to the exercise
how as as adults um how much do we need
to exercise every day to try to keep
reasonably fit
i mean i'm a believer in a short you
know short burst of exercise i think
20 to 30 minutes a day you know of kind
of focused episode is enough i also
think you know being active walking
going for bike rides you know getting
out the house doing the gardening all
these things help all these little but
every bit of movement helps i think find
something you love if it's swimming if
it's cycling and focus on that but you
know don't be hard on yourself if you do
miss a day of exercise it's not the end
of the world but i always say you know
don't exercise just to lose weight for
your body image like really good for the
mind for your mental health and how you
feel and then the physical
transformation will come because that's
what's going to motivate you it's how
you feel at the end of a workout when
you feel energized you feel less
stressed you feel happier and you know
that's just tapping into that thing and
that's going to bring you back to the
exercise every day intrigued to know
what you think joe about the 80 20 rule
in that you know you can do as much
exercise if you want but it's got to be
80 if you want to lose weight 80 percent
of it is how much you eat 20 of it is
exercise do you agree with those numbers
i mean nutrition is so important you
know you can't out train a bad diet what
i would say i've just had my birthday
weekend loads of cake lots of nice food
you know bourbon chips at the pub and a
nice sunday roast but i was active i
kept moving and
at the end of the day it's about balance
isn't it i probably do live my life 80
healthy active you know enjoying myself
and then 20
more laid back more relaxed having days
off enjoying an ice cream so i think
it's about balance it's not about
cutting things out and you know the key
to it really is enjoying cooking like
getting into the kitchen and enjoying
the process of cooking good food for you
and your family and then just doing
something activity-wise that
makes you feel good you don't want to
take yourself to a gym if you really
hate that environment you know get into
hiking don't join a club join a team or
something there's other ways of staying
active that isn't just like smashing
weights and doing high-intensity burpees
and squat jumps there's things you can
do that you're going to go to now this
doesn't feel like exercise but i'm
enjoying it and i'm getting out and i'm
moving my body and that could be enough
for you we can't not uh given that the
mats behind you we can't not let you do
a couple of exercises for you my trainer
at the moment he's got has got me doing
mounting climbers with a twist now i
absolutely hate those i don't know if
you know them and and do you think that
they are particularly effective
do you know what mountain timers aren't
as bad but when you do the twist when
you bring your knee across the body
there's so much harder i don't know why
but your shoulders go you want to
collapse on the floor but yeah it's a
good exercise for your upper body and
your abs and stuff um i'll show you the
first exercise so from from from work at
one it's called the rainbow badge and
this is the first workout on the hey
workout series um really simple you
basically have a nice wide stance and
you bring your arms up and over so you
go to the left foot up reach for the
stars and touch the right foot so we're
sort of following the arch of a rainbow
that is our first one so nice and simple
um the second one
classic he would remove the star jump
badge which will be nice and simple
hands around the head and we're just
jumping into the star jumps and then
another really great one that the kids
love is just the kind of marching on the
spots you can do it nicely just lifting
those knees up a little bit more lying
packed or if you want to sprint for goal
like sprint badge you can sprint as
quick as you can
and lift those knees up nice and fast
and that's going to raise your heart
rate get you feeling great and um give
you your very own workout badge of hey
dougie that's fantastic and that's for
kids go on do us a couple of exercises
for moms and dads who are watching as
well
okay so one for the lower body biggest
muscle group we have so you know nice
simple squats just sitting down into
that imaginary chair bending those knees
standing up nice and straight imagine
you're sort of lowering yourself into a
chair
drive through the heels that's really
going to work
those legs and another great one
classic a lunge where you're just going
to step back so feet together
and then we sort of alternate from the
leg back
that's another great one for your thighs
and your glutes
and it's really about
doing what works for you if you can't
get right down into a squat you know you
can do a half squat like a kind of
gentle one you can use some band or some
dumbbells to make it tougher but look i
always say to the message all movement
is good for you
do something today that's going to make
you feel good like do it for your mental
health for your energy don't worry about
the fat loss and losing the weight and
all that sort of stuff that's going to
come over time do it to feel good and
then that's what the huggy bag is all
about you can find them on my youtube
channel which is the body coach tv
excellent now tell me about your
birthday weekend
oh you're laughing at this i went to
lulworth cove down in dorset i've got
these amazing jet boards so me and rosie
went my mom had the kids for two nights
we stayed in this little guest house
i've got a jet board it's a surfboard
with an engine so i'm on the jetboard
going along having the best time ever i
flood the engine i can't start it and
i'm stranded in the sea the road whizzes
back to the mainland to get a boat and
luckily this little sort of dinghy went
past and i waved them down and said and
they waved i said hi mate and i said no
help so they came over and saved me and
basically they were a group of guys
called um clean jurassic post and they
spend their day they dedicate their day
to cleaning the beach off of plastic and
rubbish and and would you believe it
they ended up rescuing me and cleaning
me yeah
that's what happened on my birthday in
la worth code oh that's amazing great
big shout out to them uh they saved your
life is what they did joe this saved
your life um just tell me very quickly
again you rush through how um people
find out more about this um preschool
exercise for kids
so i'm posting one workout a day for the
next sort of thirteen days and they're
on my youtube channel just search the
body coach tv and you'll find the aw
workout series in like a sort of um
group there and you're gonna you can
yeah one a day and i really hope you
give your kids a chance to try them
because they're fun and they're gonna
you know if they're a little bit um
anxious or stressed or need a little bit
of energy a little bit of energy out
they're going to really love these
workouts so yeah check them out and
thanks for your time